tutti quelli che incontri
ti chiedono sempre
Se hai un lavoro Se sei sposato se
possiedi una casa
come se la vita fosse una specie di
lista della spesa
Ma nessuno ti chiede mai
se sei veramente felice
e oggi Voglio chiedervi siete felici
veramente felici facciamo un gioco alzi
la mano chi
oggi adesso o almeno una volta non è
felice
vi chiedo di guardarvi intorno e
ricordare all'incirca quanti siete
perché ci ritornerà utile Ok Io penso
che tutti noi vogliamo essere felici
vogliamo essere felici
l'essere umano ambisce alla felicità al
raggiungimento di un equilibrio di un
benessere che lo facciano stare bene
Noi siamo una specie più intelligente
del mondo
gli animali più complessi che esistono
sulla faccia della terra
eppure non siamo stati capaci di trovare
quella felicità
per tanti anni abbiamo sofferto siamo
entrati in un tunnel buio fatto di
guerre
odio ingiustizie che ci ha allontanato
dal vero senso delle cose
Ma io credo che se oggi tutti noi
pensiamo insieme con le nostre menti e i
nostri cuori
riusciremo a trovare una risposta
riusciremo a vivere meglio noi oggi non
viviamo bene soffriamo e siamo tristi ma
perché
cos'è che ci fa stare così male
c'erano una volta due fratelli molto
simili tra loro ma così diversi
uno dei due amava accumulare oggetti ne
possedeva tantissimi di tutti i tipi
amava accumulare computer vestiti e
tappi di bottiglie
questi oggetti li andava ad accumulare
intere stanze in cui però facevano la
polvere e quando ci entrava per
ammirarli ne usciva ogni volta
starnutendo riempiendosi i polmoni di
quelle schifezze
Certo era molto ricco
Ecco c'era anche l'altro fratello
lui preferiva passare le giornate
ascoltando musica
passeggiando nei boschi
e poi aveva una particolare attività
nelle belle giornate di primavera
amava sdraiarsi sui prati
e guardare le nuvole
provando a immaginarsi cosa gli volevano
dire
e quando le nuvole non c'erano e il
cielo era tutto azzurro
si Immaginava di nuotare in quel mare
infinito
il tempo passava i fratelli ben chiaro
e arrivò la morte ma prima che questa
ricosse entrambi furono presi in delle
riflessioni sulle loro vite quello che
amava accumulare oggetti
andava così riflettendo in punto di
morte
per tanti anni
ho accumulato oggetti
ora ce li ho sono con me
ma saranno sempre con me
tra poco morò
e me ne andrò solo
ho sprecato una vita
ad accumulare oggetti
Avrei potuto usare al meglio il mio
tempo
e con questa domanda morì
e l'altro fratello invece in punto di
morte si sedette
chiuse gli occhi
e pensavo a quella volta che aveva
aiutato quella piccola rondine caduta
dal nido
penso a quella volta che aveva aiutato
quell'uomo così disperato
penso quella volta che aveva aiutato e
amato la sua donna con tutto il suo
cuore
fece un respiro profondo
in dolcezza e tranquillità
prima vi ho chiesto di alzare la mano se
non eravamo felici Adesso chiedo alle
stesse persone di alzare la mano
se stanno bene economicamente
Ok guardatevi intorno cosa notate sul
numero delle persone che ha alzato la
mano
è molto diverso o più o meno è lo stesso
il numero ok potete abbassarla Grazie
come è diversissimo o è simile Molto sì
E quindi cosa possiamo concludere
scusa
Ma se i soldi non fanno la felicità
allora cosa fanno deve essere qualcosa
che sembra la felicità che noi abbiamo
creduto per tanti anni essere la
felicità ma di cui ci siamo illusi
cosa può essere questa cosa
la comodità la giacenza voi stessi
L'avete detto i soldi non causano la
felicità ma la comodità e sono molto
simili
Questo significa che ci possono essere
ricchi tristi e Poveri ma felici Beh la
storia è piena di questi esempi un
esempio recente che mi viene in mente è
quello di Robin Williams attore di fama
mondiale morto pochi anni fa di suicidio
Beh attore di fama mondiale penso
Insomma che era ricco Eppure se ha fatto
quella scelta estrema significa che
dentro di lui c'era qualcosa
che lo faceva fare e lo faceva star male
ma poi pensiamo anche a tutte le
dipendenze che i soldi e in genere la
cumulazione di oggetti porta Insomma
sembra che in questa società conti più
l'avere che l'essere Quindi se siete
d'accordo possiamo concludere che
la realtà materiale non causa la
felicità ma se la realtà materiale non
causa la felicità quale realtà Allora la
causa che è opposta
Beh se non è la materiale
e quella in materiale e qual è quella
parte di realtà immateriale che fa parte
delle emozioni che più ci causa felicità
è L'amore lo abbiamo scoperto abbiamo
scoperto come essere felici L'amore ci
causa la felicità Adesso chiedo alle
persone che adesso sono innamorate o che
lo sono state se vogliono condividerlo
con noi di dire le sensazioni le
emozioni che avevano quando erano o
quando sono innamorati
protezione
Beh lo state dicendo voi stessi e
l'amore che ci fa sentire vivi
nell'azzurro del cielo nel verde dei
prati nel vento che ci parla e nel sole
che ci illumina si sente la vita la vera
vita che non ha bisogno di soldi per
resistere non ha bisogno di oggetti per
mostrarsi ma vive dell'amore ed è solo
amore che la porta avanti e la fa vivere
fuori di noi e dentro di noi
e nell'amore noi troveremo la vita
provate già solo immaginare come può
essere stupenda una vita senza odio in
cui regna la pace e la tranquillità una
vita in cui
tutti ci si aiutano a vicenda e si porge
la mano a chi è caduto una vita in cui
nessuno si sente solo abbandonato ma
tutti partecipano alla stessa felicità
che ci unisce e uniti supereremo ogni
difficoltà una vita in cui si vive con
la natura e non sopra la natura in cui
la si usa per vivere e non la si sfrutta
per guadagnare una natura madre che non
matrigna che possa essere lo scenario di
una convivenza pacifica tra animali e
persone e tra persone
e persone
Dunque abbiamo visto che i soldi non
causano la felicità
che l'amore causa la felicità ma vi
posso dire una cosa in più
Pensate ad almeno un problema che c'è
attualmente nel mondo o che c'è stato
almeno uno
ce l'avete in mente tutti Ok adesso vi
dirò che la causa di quel problema ma
attenzione non la causa recente proprio
quella che sta alla base alla radice
quella più profonda la primissima causa
di questo problema
sono propri soldi e questo che possa
servirvi anche nella vita anche in
futuro ogni volta che c'è un problema
che affligge tutto il mondo quasi
sicuramente alla causa ci sono proprio i
soldi quindi abbiamo visto che i soldi
non solo non causano la felicità ma che
ci rovinano anche rovinano i rapporti
tra umani li degradano
Ecco io pensavo per esempio la figura
dell'arrampicatore sociale non so se la
conoscete questa figura l'uomo che fa di
tutto pur di arrivare a un posto di
lavoro alto e poi degli altri
chissenefrega Ovviamente questo proprio
in funzione dei soldi ma anche voi
potete fare un sacco di esempi su
persone che hanno messo davanti prima i
soldi e poi la vita dell'altro
quindi oggi abbiamo visto che
i soldi non causano felicità voi stessi
lo avete detto che l'amore causa la
felicità voi stessi lo avete detto e che
i soldi non solo non causano felicità
Ma che sono anche la causa dei problemi
del mondo
quest'oggi Noi abbiamo scoperto cose
che molti prima di noi non avevano
scoperto
abbiamo scoperto come essere felici
come vivere veramente e non solo
esistere
abbiamo trovato la chiave che apre la
porta alla vera vita quella in cui si
vive tutti insieme e non ognuno contro
l'altro
e ora
tocca a noi aprire quella porta
ognuno di noi uscendo da questa stanza
avrà il suo metodo
chi non restando indifferente alle
ingiustizie
chi rispettando il prossimo
chi aiutandolo
potete agire come volete
Vi chiedo solo una cosa
agite amando e vi prometto che la vostra
vita sarà meravigliosa grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]